hey guys P here this is gonna be my
Westworld season 1 episode 8 review a
ton of stuff happened to get set up for
the last two episodes this video will
have spoilers if you aren't cut up
through episode 8 so proceed with
caution there's a lot of trickery and
confusing bits in the episode so I tried
not to go down any rabbit holes during
the recap part I'll put a timestamp link
in the description too when the
discussion theory section starts so you
can skip right to that if you want and
the first scene we see Ford bring
Bernard back on line which is a cool
twist on what we've seen before
he immediately remembers what he's done
to Theresa
Ford explains to him that he built him
because the human engineers weren't up
to the task of providing him what he
wanted he says the original host
emotions were primary colors and he
wanted all the shades in between he
tells him that gathered they captured
that elusive thing part Bernard is
confused and feeling real pain he tells
40 loved her and asked why he made him
do it
Ford explains that one man's life or
death was but a small price to pay for
the acquirement of the knowledge which
he sought for the Dominion he should
acquire Bernard refuses to continue and
then starts to freak out
Ford freezes him and says that Bernard
is not the first man to threaten him
Arnold came to feel the way he does he
couldn't stop me either
Ford also says the only thing more
sublime than creating this array of
emotions is being able to turn them off
he sets Bernard back to his old self and
then he puts his glasses back on and
asks how would you like me to proceed we
see the command center while we hear
Ford's instruction he says he needs him
to clean up his mess any connection that
ties us to Teresa's demise we see
Bernard going around moving details that
would put him in the same place as her
and here Ford say that once he's done he
will give him the thing he wants most
right now he'll remove his memories of
what he did to Teresa and all the
memories to their relationship see
Bernard collecting evidence and then
destroying it at a high
Tek incinerator Ford says that he'll
remember Teresa as a respected colleague
from there we go to the Mariposa where
we see Maeve and clementines new
replacement her name is still Clem that
Maeve doesn't look to be enjoying the
replacement she just stares at her when
she asks her if something's wrong we're
here the House of the Rising Sun playing
on the player piano and when Maeve is
looking confused the sound slows down
she then sees herself with her child in
the old story next she's with Felix and
Sylvester and asking them what's
happening to her she explains that she's
jumping between the stories and can't
tell which is real Sylvester says this
is what happens when you [ __ ] around
with your brain Felix explains the
villain in a little more detail that
they're designed differently than people
whose memories are hazy on details she
remembers memories perfectly she relives
them maybe then asked about the little
girl and her dreams is she still in the
park somewhere and why was she
reassigned in the first place
Felix says he can check but she says no
saying everything she remembers is a
story created by the park to keep her
there that's not going to work anymore
because she's getting out from there we
find out that every host has an
explosive charge in their spine that
will detonate if they try to leave Felix
points out that she would need a total
rebuild to remove it which doesn't slow
me down at all then he says even if she
pulled that off she would need an army
to get out she tells them it's time to
write her own [ __ ] story and starts
to use their pad to put her plan of
getting allies together in motion
William and Delores are riding up on the
river and she tells him she's been there
before that they're close when he asked
close to what she says home she walks
through a clearing and finds a bunch of
dead Confederate OHS with one clinging
to life William asked him about if they
came for them and asked how they knew
about the Train he explains a new
recruit told them that a woman and a man
had double-crossed them and then William
responds logan Flores walks over to the
water to collect some in the canteen to
give the dying man she slips into a
memory that shows she's been there
before she hears a voice it doesn't
sound like Bernard say find me
she then sees her own dead
in the water and when she looks back
doesn't see William for a second she
comes back to present time and when she
walks over to the Confederate oh and
William he dies stops tells Ford and
Charlotte that they found Teresa's body
in a ravine on Python Pass the same
ravine where they found the straight
woodcutter from that point on we get a
grand display of Ford's strategy and
power stub says the injuries are
consistent with a fall and shows them
that they found transmitters with the
body he points out that she may have
been behind the woodcutter and when it
failed she tried to do it herself he
goes tip four tattwas Charlotte some and
then reveals that he knows someone from
Q & A altered the code to make
Clementine put on her little display he
says that they should take over until
the QA people can be replaced and then
puts Bernard back in his job since he
was fired on false pretenses it's a
gripping scene that ends there but we
can see it's clearly a chess game
between Charlotte for which he won
Teresa basically becomes collateral
damage and the next scene Maeve looks to
be casually using the touchpad as Felix
is trying to look busy
Sylvester comes back and says there's a
major problem in the park and an
investigation he says it's not about
them but they should quit messing around
with Maeve right away she hands the
touchpad back and says she found out
what she needed to learn she explains
there are some things in her that are
quite old that there are dormant things
which she's designed to do but are just
out of her reach it's as if there are
two Minds arguing with each other in the
code then she asked who is Arnold what
Sen Sylvester into a rant saying they
can't do anything for her about the
dormant things she needs the people and
behavior for that of course she tells
them that she needs to get in there and
that there is a window during the shift
change she adds what she needs them to
do is quite complicated but she'll write
it down for them they go outside the
room and Sylvester tells Felix of his
plan to take her up there and wipe her
clean neither of them seem very
confident about the plan but they see it
as their only chance to fix their
situation the man in black and Teddy are
riding and Ted
tells him to be careful that they are
now and why it's territory they talk
some as they go about how Teddy only
remembers what Ford lets him remember
and how the game is raked when he says
he is there to play the loser we see
Teddy flashback to when we saw him say
that to him the last time in episode one
they come across some dead bodies and
one host that is still alive it's the
host that welcomed William when he first
arrived only she's playing a different
role the man in black recognizes her
right away and says it's you thought
they would have retired you guess Lord
doesn't like to get rid of a pretty face
while teddy is tending to her the man in
black looks around we hear a noise and
then one of Wyatts men attacked Teddy
shoots him which doesn't slow him down
although we see that the bullets go in
rather than bouncing off like they do
with people the man in black stabs him
in the back but he just gets Pat like
pushed right out of the way he then
grabs a rope and wraps it around the
guys neck while he's pulling on the guy
Teddy remember seeing him dragging
Dolores eventually Teddy uses the axe to
kill the attacker the man in black says
well you don't remember anything but you
still managed to lead us to why it screw
the man himself must be close by Teddy
gets up to say actually I do remember
something you and then pistol whips him
knocking him out things move right along
and mave story as we see them wheeling
her into behavior she pairs up with the
computer then asked Felix if he's sure
he's up to this he says they have to
shut her down now and in an awesome move
she says Sylvester good luck as she
looks at him when Felix shuts her down
she freezes that way he's just staring
at her the scene ends with Felix
thinking about reformatting her Lisa is
Mars working on a new host when
Charlotte walks in she tells him that
three sad eyed doing something important
for the board she also tells him that
Ford is having him do busy work but that
she thinks he's ready for a real job
apparently he thought he was designing
Wyatt for Ford's new narrative we see
Sylvester trying to console Felix after
wiping Maebh out she pops up and says he
didn't do it
instead he did exactly what she asked
him to do she asked if he would like to
know what they're up to
and then
says they've been changing her core
coding she gets up and slices
Sylvester's throat with the scalpel
Felix is shocked and says she promised
not to hurt anyone and she tells him
that you of all people should know
exactly how duplicitous
I am just wait until I'm back up top
practicing my other new talents she
didn't gives him a device and says come
on we might need him we learned that he
can use use it to heal the slash that
maybe just gave Sylvester after he saves
his life Maeve says now it's time to
recruit my army see you wake up and then
see she see her looking at a pocket
watch in the mariposa the new Clementine
comes over to ask if she's waiting for
someone she says yes an old friend from
out of town and then the bartender comes
up behind he says he hopes the friend
has deep pockets because her tab is
getting out of hand she looks at him and
says no Maeve stab was in such excellent
standing that she deserved a token of
gratitude
he sort of freezes while she says this
and then offers her a double round of
top-shelf on him after she has the drink
she sees a small child with her mother
outside she relives her memory in the
old storyline and this time we see the
man in black stabbed her in the abdomen
she comes back to in the mariposa
holding her stomach and then takes
control of Clementine and then the
bartender she has clen get the other
girls and take the men playing cards at
the front table upstairs on the house
and has the bartender remember that he
has some whiskey out back he needs to
water down
Hector shows up right on time and Maeve
helps him every step of the way she
messes with the sheriff and the marshals
and Hector can get the safe out at the
mariposa Maeve has a satisfying look on
her face as she realizes she can rewrite
the narratives in real time Fortis with
Bernard and it looks like he is removing
his painful memories of Teresa Bernard
brings up Charlotte but Ford says
they'll be able to handle her he notices
Ford has something else on his mind
which starts a conversation Ford says
that Bernard is in a unique position
he's a programmer who knows how the
machines work and a machine that knows
its own true nature Bernard says he
knows how he's coded but doesn't
understand the things that he feels he
asked if his wife and son are real and
Ford reminds him that
every host has a backstory the self is
the story that we tell ourselves and it
needs to have a beginning
Bernard's suffering makes him lifelike
bernard asks lifelike but not alive
he says pain only exists in the mind so
what's the difference between my pain
and yours between you and me
Ford says this was the very question
that consumed Arnold filled him with
guilt eventually turned him mad he says
the answer always seemed obvious to him
there is no threshold that makes the sum
greater than its parts no inflection
point at which we become fully alive we
can't define consciousness because
consciousness doesn't exist he says that
humans fancy that there is something
special about the way we perceive the
world yet we live in loops as tight and
closed as the hosts do he tells Bernard
he isn't missing anything and then gets
ready to remove that part of his memory
until Bernard says wait one last thing
he asked if he's ever made him hurt
anyone like this before to which Ford
answers no then we see him have a
flashback of choking l see William and
Dolores arrive at the river and she says
she's home we see there's a town there
that she approaches as she walks up she
slips into a memory and we see her
clothes change and the town becomes
filled with hosts we start to notice
that it's the city from the flashback
when Ford was telling Bernard about the
early days at the park before the guests
arrive we see the white church in the
background and then Lawrence's daughter
walks up to say good morning and asked
the loris if she found what she was
looking for we hear a gunshot
and the little girl takes off as we see
there are dead hosts everywhere on the
ground we see that it looks like a male
host is shooting the others but then see
what looks like the not Dolores looking
at herself as she puts the gun up to her
head wearing the blue dress we see her
change back to real time with real
William running up to stop her she seems
lost because she can't tell what's real
anymore she says when are we is this now
am I going mad are you real
William reassures her he is real and
then she tells him she feels like she's
stuck in a dream his remedy is to get
her away from where they
because he thinks her being so far from
Sweetwater is causing the problem we see
that the white church is no longer there
and that only the skeleton of the
steeple remains when Delores notices she
has a flashback and she tells William
this is what Arnold wants he wants me to
remember William says that whoever
Arnold is he isn't there but William is
so she needs to get out of the location
as they're walking she says she was
almost certain that that was where she
was supposed to go that Arnold would
meet her there as they continue up the
trail Logan comes up with a group of
soldiers he says he's been looking for
them for days and man are you two [ __ ]
Charlotte and Lee are in cold storage
and we noticed the old logo on the doors
as they passed through we find out
Charlotte's plan is to copy 35 years of
bodily important data to Peter Abernathy
she tells him that a host mind has more
capacity than any Drive especially once
they've been wiped clean like he has
Lee's job is to give Peter some
semblance of a personality so that he
can make it out of the Train on the
train out of the park Lee doesn't
understand how he's supposed to do that
but she leaves him with the tasks and
tells him to figure it out sub catches
up with Bernard implies that he knows
Teresa's death must be hard on him
because of their fare it seems like
Ford's memory-wipe worked because he
looks like he doesn't know what Stubbs
is talking about they go back and forth
a bit and Bernard just basically stays
on script which notice Lee confuses the
hell out of Stubbs when Bernard says he
has to get back to work Stubbs also
asked if he's heard from Elsie he says
he tried to get in touch with her about
Teresa but didn't hear back Bernard
basically says she's probably off
enjoying her time and just walks away we
see that Teddy has the man in black tied
up and is talking to Angela who's
telling him about why it's men the man
in black comments that it looks like you
two found yourselves and a new narrative
together
Teddy says he has spent a long time with
yet knows nothing about him and happily
he's figured out how to make him talk he
starts beating him up and he tells him
that he remembers what he did to Dolores
the man in black responds you're
actually remembering Teddy says he's
gonna kill him slow and Ed Harris says
no he won't the rules of this place hold
him back but he knows how to change them
Teddy says he talks like he owns the
world and he replies not just this one
he tells him he's a God Titan of
industry philanthropist family man
married to a beautiful woman father to a
beautiful daughter I'm the good guy
Teddy he then explains that last year
his wife took the wrong pills and fell
asleep in the bathtub at her funeral his
daughter told him that she did it on
purpose
killed herself and that it was basically
the man in blacks fault Teddy asked if
he hurt them too what she says he never
did they never saw anything like the man
he is in there
the men in black says he came back to
Westworld to prove her wrong only this
time he didn't join one of Ford stories
he devised his own a test he found an
ordinary woman which was made in her old
story who we then see in present time
back at the mariposa she tells the new
Clementine that she's leaving and we see
her walk outside we hear the man in
black story continue he says he wanted
to see if he could do something truly
evil as Maeve's walking there's a
gunshot that we see kicks in the memory
of the man in blacks visit Maeve's on
the ground with the knife in her stomach
and her daughter is moving across the
room scared man in black continues to
tell the story to Teddy he says that he
shot the little girl just to see how it
felt but just as he was done Maeve had
refused to die as we see her pull them
out knife out and slash at his throat we
cut back to her in the street to see
that she's cut clementines through Teddy
calls him an animal but the man in black
counters that an animal would have felt
something he felt nothing but then
something miraculous happened in all his
years coming there he'd never seen
anything like it received Maeve Carey
her daughter outside as he watches and
he tells us she was truly a
if only for a moment that is when the
maze revealed itself to him Teddy asked
what the damn pattern has to do with
this he replies everything in fours game
he can go to the outer edges but nothing
can hurt him he knows there's a deeper
game
Arnold's game and that game cuts deep we
look back at maven see people are
closing in to capture her now that she's
killed Clem in the middle of the street
she eludes the host and makes it back to
her room by controlling the story so
that one of them shoots the other ones
who were chasing her but there we see
that the detect that Stubbs sent are
basically closing in on her she looks in
the mirror and falls into another memory
she's back at the center after the man
in black incident and the text can't
control her with voice commands Ford and
Bernard show up and they see that her
cognition is fragmented Ford erases the
memory saying an old trick from an old
friend
you need not suffer may've I'll take it
from you may please she doesn't want him
to do it since that pain is all she has
left to remember her daughter Ford
continues and explains that tomorrow
this will all be a distant dream as he
finishes we see her grab a scalpel to
plunge in her neck and then we see her
back in real time looking in the mirror
again we see her plotting her next move
as we see the text getting close we hear
them say that behavior once heard down
for an immediate diagnostic we finished
up with the man in black who says that
the maze is the only thing that matters
now
best thing white is the last step to
getting to it and giving both their
lives what they lack a meaning even if
it kills them
Angela speaks up to tell Teddy to kill
him he says he's tied and unarmed - what
she responds so was the little girl he
killed Teddy pulls his gun but can't do
it and then Angela says she can help she
stabs Teddy in the chest with an arrow
and tells him it's time he came back to
the fold
she says Wyatt will need him soon and
then we see his men start coming out of
the woods the man in black looks on and
the scene ends with a large group of
them advancing so this was a crazy
episode chock full of stuff first things
first is it just me or did the man in
black confirm
alternate timeframes when he sees Angela
who is the host that welcome William to
the park he says I thought they would
have retired you I'm not sure how
non-believers of William and the man in
black being at the park at different
times can explain this one away to me
that theory seems to be confirmed by
this blatant reference although it was
already looking solid before that let me
know what you guys think in the comments
though I don't want to go on and on
about it I just think that that's a
pretty straightforward clue that there's
two different time frames in the show
may pretty much has the force now it's
really interesting because we are seeing
this parallel story with her and Bernard
Ford is talking about how Bernard has
reached a new place knowing that he's a
machine
while at the same time totally
understanding how things work Maeve is
basically right there with him but also
may have advanced beyond him since she
doesn't seem to be under Ford's thumb
she can rewrite the narratives in real
time which is something we haven't seen
Bernard ever do before I mean we it's
been clear that not only is Bernard a
host but he's a special kind of host he
can do different things he can remember
things so on and so forth Maeve almost
seems like she just leapfrogged them
into the lead for the craziest most
capable host now though I don't know I
know by the end of the episode she looks
to be trapped and that things aren't
really going her way but I think it
would be a mistake to miss to
underestimate her at this point I don't
think it was all part of her plan
because the memory looked like it threw
things off but that said I can't imagine
that she won't pull out some sort of
back-up plan before all said and done
we're gonna have to talk about LC and
the only thing I can say is she dead is
LC dead to me the shot looked like
Bernard was choking her with her feet
off the ground which is pretty deadly
were the possible scenarios were that
wouldn't have killed her I mean now
there's the thing where she could be a
hose since everyone could be a host but
are there any other options it doesn't
feel like the end of her story I mean
that's what I thought anyways she's a
major character so it seems cheap if
they just kill her off in a short memory
I think we'll learn more and frankly
hope so because I'd like to see Anne
where she isn't dead because I really
like the character is for just messing
with Bernard I mean obviously he's
messing with Bernard but the whole idea
of him not believing that Bernard is
missing anything compared to humans or
is he really playing God but the idea
that hosts are maybe an upgrade for
humans and that they can remember things
perfectly but can also have those
memories wiped out if they become an
impediment do you guys think he made
them remember things that way on purpose
the name of the episode is Trace decay
which is the theory about how we forget
in really simple terms it relates to
what Felix was telling me about how
memories are fuzzy on the details from
what I understand Trace decay says that
our memories produce some kind of trace
physical chemical that starts to decay
over time
imagine that Ford knows about this which
makes me think he might have made a
conscious decision to make the host
different in that way I mean think about
it what he tells Bernard about his
cornerstone he says that self is the
story that we tell ourselves the hosts
have clear memories which we see is
causing problems but they're also
designed in a way that he can keep tight
control of them if they glitch out it
reinforces the idea he's playing God I
think it makes it look like he is making
them into what he perceives as perfect
beings the question I guess is what is
his end goal for these perfect beings
the old steeple was like thrown in there
as a trick about the time frame since we
see it in present like that or we did
anyways whenever Ford was looking around
planning the new narrative but it also
separates the building phase from when
the park was in its early days dolorous
his memories are confusing her in the
same way that Maeve's are only we
believe that this is happening to
Dolores long before and possibly as a
direct result of something Arnold did
the lorises story kind of went backwards
in some ways in this episode since we
see William pull her back when she
thinks she's getting close it's also
confusing to me because Ford has tied
this into the new narrative he created
with the white church what I think we
definitely learned though
was that something major happen with the
host before they ever open up West world
to the guests and even though there's
nothing clear about it we know that even
though Maeve's not one of the bicameral
hosts or at least we haven't seen that
she does have that coating that is
triggering the same thing that it did in
Dolores all that time ago we learned a
little more about Arnold and a lot more
about the man in black Bernard is or was
struggling with the same problem that
Arnold had it's hard for him to
understand what makes the host different
since they experience real feelings if
we trust Ford's retelling it drove
Arnold mad but we see him attempt to nip
it in the bud with Bernard the Elsie
flashback makes you wonder how effective
that whole thing was though I'm not sure
we got enough in her information to
understand why why it's men are so tough
to kill but it was cool to see Angela
come back in a different role it was
also interesting to learn about the man
in blacks backstory even if the details
of what he does for a living are pretty
baked the event that turned him into
what came off to us as you know it came
off to us as pure evil when we first met
him in the beginning that works why he
killed Maeve and her daughter that works
too and this all could explain how
someone like nice guy William might have
turned into the character even if they
don't look that much alike not a
confirmation in a show like this but it
does confirm that the man in black is in
no way concerned with his own life
the mayor's reveal is and it's not
something when you look at and say oh
that now that all makes sense we can
understand why he did what he did but
can only guess as to why she falls down
to die right on top of the maize pattern
I think at this point we should probably
just leave it there please like the
video if you enjoyed it and please
subscribe to my channel so you don't
miss any of my new videos leave me some
comments if you have questions theories
or ideas about how these last two
episodes are gonna go down you can also
find me on Twitter most of the time if
you want to continue the conversation
there thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon